Où est-ce qu'on est aujourd'hui ?
On n'est pas la maison, bien qu’il y ait de la brique, non.
On est aujourd'hui à Paris, dans un lieu qui est très sympa.
Vous allez le découvrir lors d'une interview.
C'est aujourd'hui un sujet qui est réalisé en partenariat avec Huawei, qui est venu
me voir et m'a dit : « Tiens, Monsieur GRrr ! On aimerait parler d'HarmonyOS,
on aimerait parler de l’AppGallery,
on aimerait parler de tout notre écosystème. »
Je leur ai dit : « Bien évidemment, on va y aller. C'est parti ! »
On va se faire aujourd'hui une interview de Stéphane Curtelin.
Vous allez tout savoir.
Vous allez être incollables
parce que vous me posez beaucoup de questions en commentaires,
donc on va tout regarder, aujourd'hui, ensemble.
Toutes les questions sont là, regardez !
On peut même se faire un petit éventail avec, c’est très pratique.
Je peux même faire de l'air parce qu'il fait très chaud aujourd'hui.
Et surtout, on va se poser ces questions aujourd'hui.
Sept questions, voire un petit peu plus si affinités
à Stéphane Curtelin. Vous êtes prêts ? C'est parti, on y va.
Pour te présenter rapidement Stéphane, tu es, j’ai tout sur ma petite fiche,
Directeur Marketing Consumer Business Group de Huawei France.
Voilà, c’est sur la partie des produits grand public.
On attaque directement avec les questions.
J'ai une première question à te poser : depuis les sanctions américaines,
vos nouveaux smartphones et tablettes n'ont plus accès aux services Google.
Comme alternative, vous avez développé les Huawei Mobile Services,
ce qu'on appellera les HMS.
Est-ce que tu peux nous les présenter et nous dire où est-ce que vous en êtes dans leur déploiement en France ?
Alors, les Huawei Mobile Services, c'est l'accès aux services dont vous avez besoin
qu'on a créé par nous-mêmes pour justement remplacer les Google Mobile Services.
À quoi les Huawei Mobile Services permettent d'avoir accès ?
Quels sont ces services dont on a besoin ?
Les applications mobiles, celles que l’on a sur son smartphone.
Ça permet désormais à 173000 applications dans le monde
d'être disponibles sur notre propre store d'applications : la Huawei AppGallery.
Et c'est l'occasion d'ailleurs de reconnaître le travail fait par plus de 5 millions de développeurs dans le monde
qui ont rejoint justement cette aventure de la Huawei AppGallery.
C'est aussi, en plus des applications mobiles, de plus en plus des services proposés par Huawei.
Donc, c’est par exemple Huawei Music.
On est aussi en train de développer, de plus en plus, un service de cartographie qui s'appelle Petal Maps.
Donc, l'histoire continue dans ce sens là.
C’est vrai que les consommateurs sur Android sont habitués aux services de Google.
Ça peut être une crainte pour les consommateurs de se dire : « OK, on va abandonner
d'un côté les GMS, les Google Mobile Services, au profit des Huawei Mobiles Services. »
Qu'est ce que tu dirais aux utilisateurs pour les convaincre de venir sur vos propres services ?
Et quels sont les avantages, mais aussi aujourd'hui, les inconvénients, voire les limites qu'on peut retrouver avec les HMS ?
La question est très légitime et c'est bien qu'on puisse l'aborder.
Ce que je leur dirais, à ces utilisateurs ou futurs utilisateurs, c'est déjà : « Essayez-les ! », pour se rendre compte que, justement,
cette Huawei AppGallery bâtie sur ces HMS, ces Huawei Mobile Services, apporte vraiment des réponses
pour les usages du quotidien.
Ils vont pouvoir retrouver les applications les plus populaires. Ils vont pouvoir retrouver aussi des applications qui ne sont pas développées en France.
Et je pense notamment à Facebook, Instagram, Snapchat, Twitter, TikTok, qui sont parmi les plus populaires.
Donc on a vraiment maintenant un ensemble de solutions pour répondre aux besoins légitimes, justement,
parce que ça fait partie de l'utilisation de son smartphone au quotidien.
C’est vrai que pour attirer les consommateurs en nombre, il faut beaucoup d'applications qui correspondent à leurs besoins,
comme tu disais très justement à l'instant.
Sur vos smartphones et sur vos tablettes, les applications sont disponibles,
comme tu le disais, dans votre catalogue d'applications qui s'appelle l’AppGallery.
Les catalogues d'applications concurrents occupent déjà beaucoup les développeurs.
Ma question se tourne plutôt du côté développeur : quelles stratégies et quels outils vous avez mis en place pour emmener les développeurs à venir coder spécifiquement pour l'AppGallery ?
Alors, notre envie c'est de proposer des solutions, probablement les plus ouvertes et les plus favorables, aux développeurs.
Comment ?
Un exemple : Huawei, dans le monde, a mis à disposition 1 milliard de dollars dans un programme qui s'appelle Shining Star
pour inciter justement à développer dans la Huawei AppGallery sur les Huawei Mobile Services.
Pour revenir aux applications françaises qui touchent tout le monde,
les équipes locales, dont je fais partie, travaillent avec nos partenaires :
Le Figaro, BFM TV, MyTF1, le Crédit Mutuel, etc.
Pour justement mettre à disposition de ces partenaires, petits et grands, soit des ressources humaines pour les aider avec des développeurs,
soit des ressources financières pour justement financer cette migration sur les Huawei Mobile Services.
C'est à la fois, pour le futur, ce programme Shining Star qui est lancé au niveau mondial,
et également au quotidien en local, en France, des équipes proches des partenaires pour les applications françaises pour les aider à développer.
Donc, c'est très concret.
Tu parles de 1 milliard de dollars. Est ce qu'on arrive à savoir quel est le budget qui arrive en France ?
Les clés de répartition ou pas?
Alors ce milliard de dollars est proposé et après, c'est à chacun de candidater pour sa prochaine application.
C'est pour cela que je fais bien la distinction entre les applications qui existent déjà,
où là on va les aider avec justement les équipes locales : là, ce sont des ressources au cas par cas.
Soit on passe du temps avec elles, soit on va leur apporter des ressources financières pour les aider justement à développer par eux-mêmes.
Et là, c'est plus un appel aux futurs développeurs, aux futurs développements, aux futures applications
pour qu'ils pensent également à nous et à se dire : « Tiens, moi, je veux lancer une nouvelle application,
pourquoi pas me lancer sur la Huawei AppGallery et faire appel, candidater
pour avoir une partie de ce financement. »
Après, le financement il est évalué en fonction des besoins de développement
et on en revient justement aux Huawei Mobile Services : qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière ces Huawei Mobile Services ?
Ce sont des kits. À quoi servent ces kits ?
À faire des notifications, du paiement en ligne, à faire de la cartographie.
C'est en fait une boîte à outils qui va être utilisée par les développeurs.
Et plus cette boîte à outils a besoin d'être complète, plus le financement va être important.
Et ça, ça vous permet d'avoir un vrai coup d'accélérateur pour permettre de développer aujourd'hui
l’AppGallery, le catalogue d'applications et également les Huawei Mobile Services ?
Oui, tout à fait. C'est ce qui nous a entre autre permis d'avoir plus de 1 200 applications françaises déjà disponibles dans notre store
et qui répondent, je vais citer les exemples, aux besoins d'information, de voyage, de paiement, aux besoins que l’on retrouve
dans un monde d'applications mobiles.
Je veux que l’on parle justement des différentes applications qu'on peut retrouver pour permettre de se projeter concrètement.
Quelles sont les applications qu'on peut retrouver aujourd'hui sur l’AppGallery ?
Quelles sont les applications que l'on pourra retrouver prochainement sur l’AppGallery ?
Et qu'est-ce que tu dirais aux consommateurs qui sont encore habitués aux GMS, qui utilisent Gmail,
qui utilisent Google Maps, qui ont un agenda Google et pourquoi pas leur maison Nest,
qui est connectée au quotidien?
Alors, c'est une très bonne question.
Je vais commencer par répondre à la dernière parce que c'est vrai que ça fait aussi partie du quotidien.
Si, par exemple, j'ai l'utilisation de Google Maps ou de YouTube, qui sont vraiment
des pures applications Google. Là, en effet, on a plusieurs solutions.
On a ce que l'on appelle la solution des Web Apps.
Les Web Apps, c'est quoi ?
Je crée tout simplement un raccourci sur mon smartphone qui va m'amener sur le navigateur.
Google Maps étant "responsive", comme on dit,
c'est à dire qu’il va détecter que vous accédez à Google Maps sur votre navigateur
Chrome ou n'importe lequel et va l'adapter au format du smartphone.
Et donc là, à travers cette Web App,
vous allez retrouver l'ensemble des usages que vous avez sur l'application native.
Je donne un exemple : si vous avez mis sur Google Maps vos favoris, vos restaurants
ou quelque chose que vous voulez visiter, vous allez les retrouver.
Youtube Music : vous allez retrouver votre playlist et ainsi de suite.
Donc il y a vraiment une solution qui est très concrète, qui est celle-ci.
Gmail par exemple, c'est pareil.
Ça peut être embarqué
dans notre propre système Huawei Email
qui va embarquer le client Gmail à l'intérieur.
Ou autrement on peut aussi retrouver l'accès à Gmail en passant à nouveau par le navigateur.
Je voudrais que l'on parle maintenant d'HarmonyOS.
Alors, il y a quelques mois vous présentiez HarmonyOS
qui est votre système d'exploitation qui s'inscrit dans la continuité de votre écosystème,
que vous avez présenté déjà il y a un petit moment également.
Qu'apporte HarmonyOS ?
Où est-ce que vous en êtes dans son développement ?
Est-ce que le développement d'HarmonyOS a été quelque part un peu freiné
par les sanctions américaines ?
HarmonyOS, c'est un projet fantastique.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que c'est tout simplement notre ambition, notre vision
qui est vraiment dans cette vision à long terme, indépendamment d'ailleurs
des problèmes avec l'administration américaine que nous regrettons évidemment.
Il y a une vision qui est antécédente à toutes ces complications là, à ces problèmes là,
qui est d'apporter des solutions dans le monde
pour connecter les personnes, les organisations et les maisons.
Donc, dans cette vision des télécommunications avancées,
il y a l'idée aussi de l'Internet des objets, d'intégrer l'Internet des objets.
On a tous remarqué que l'on a de plus en plus d'objets connectés.
Et donc HarmonyOS pour nous, c'est ni plus ni moins notre ambition
de proposer un OS de troisième génération.
Pourquoi "troisième génération" ?
Très simple, pour se refaire les 30 dernières années.
D'abord, on avait un système exploitation sur les PC.
Ça n'a échappé à personne, mais c'était quelque chose de centré sur un ou des PC.
Ensuite, sont arrivés les smartphones.
Là aussi, il y a eu un, puis un deuxième OS dédié aux smartphones.
Mais encore une fois, c'était dédié à un produit.
Et puis, on se rend compte que l'on connecte de plus en plus.
Donc aujourd'hui, c'est encore assez fragmenté.
Quand on arrive à appairer son smartphone avec des enceintes, on est content.
On se dit : « Ca a marché ! ».
C'est encore parfois une petite surprise.
Et nous ce que l'on veut, c'est que ce ne soit plus une surprise.
C'est que ce soit quelque chose de complètement fluide.
Et donc de passer d'un univers fragmenté à un univers connecté.
Et donc, c'est l'entrée que l'on a déjà tous senti dans l'Internet des objets.
L'Internet des objets, on se rend compte qu'à l'avenir, on n'aura pas qu'un produit connecté.
On en a déjà plusieurs. On est souvent la smart TV, le smartphone...
Et dans cette histoire de smart device, on arrive vite à avoir plusieurs objets.
L'ambition, c'est de passer d'un système d'exploitation centré sur un produit,
à un système d’exploitation qui soit distribué.
Je vais illustrer ça.
Des produits avec uniquement
128 kilo-octets de mémoire pourront avoir des codes HarmonyOS.
Ça veut dire que, je prends un exemple
qui peut paraître trivial, mais on peut les multiplier à l'infini.
Une ampoule,
une cafetière,
pourra connecter,
on pourra la piloter, même si elle a une mémoire très limitée.
C'est ouvrir des perspectives
sur cet Internet des objets avec un OS de troisième génération.
Et c'est vraiment ça l'ambition d'HarmonyOS.
Sur le marché du smartphone, il y a deux acteurs majeurs aujourd'hui.
On a d'un côté Apple avec iOS,
d'un autre côté Google avec Android.
Est-ce qu’il y a encore de la place pour un nouvel OS ?
Et en quoi HarmonyOS va être différent des autres systèmes d'exploitation?
Et qu'est ce qu'il va venir apporter de plus ?
On pense en effet qu'il y a vraiment une place pour cela,
parce qu'il y a cette idée d'apporter une solution pour l'avenir.
En tant que système d'exploitation de troisième génération.
Les autres OS qu'on vient de citer existent déjà.
Nous on veut aller plus loin en proposant cette interconnexion aisée,
fluide, intuitive au quotidien.
Et pour donner un exemple, on lance la notion de "Super Device".
C’est à dire qu'il n'y aura plus besoin de vraiment configurer de façon
parfois un peu délicate, d’appairer les produits.
Mais on aura une vision, une interface qui va vous montrer votre produit
sur lequel vous êtes en train d'agir
et les produits satellites qui pourront apparaître.
Et ils apparaîtront par eux-mêmes.
C'est à dire que l'idée, c'est que je suis en mobilité, je rentre chez moi,
mon smartphone va détecter les produits HarmonyOS,
compatibles HarmonyOS autour de moi et va me les proposer naturellement.
J’allais dire "spontanément".
Si on peut parler de "spontané" pour de la technologie.
Et donc après je choisis.
C’est à dire que ce ne sera pas envahissant, c'est moi qui vais choisir.
Je rentre. Tiens, on me propose ma télévision,
ce qui existe déjà : on a notre Huawei Vision qui est disponible en Chine.
Je peux l’appairer, ça se fait naturellement
d'un seul coup de doigt sur mon smartphone.
Et après l'histoire continue sur ma télé.
Ce que l'on veut apporter c’est cette aisance et cette interopérabilité.
Et c'est pour ça qu'on insiste sur le fait qu’HarmonyOS
est un univers très ouvert.
C'est pour ça qu'on veut être particulièrement ouvert
aux développeurs et favorable aux développeurs
en les soutenant financièrement,
en les accueillant avec les équipes locales
et en envisageant l'avenir ensemble.
De ce que tu me décris,
j'ai l'impression effectivement que vous mettez les moyens à 300 %
pour que Huawei soit aujourd’hui incontournable
dans le domaine de l'univers connecté avec le smartphone au centre
et tous les appareils autour.
C’est vrai que je teste beaucoup de vos appareils.
Je vois très bien que je peux connecter très facilement mon P40 Pro
qui va communiquer avec mon moniteur,
qui va communiquer avec mon MateBook, avec mon MateView, avec mon MatePad.
Bref, tout communique très bien ensemble.
Mais pour autant, j'ai l'impression
qu'il manque encore un petit quelque chose pour qu'il y ait une adoption grand public.
Est-ce que c'est le cas tout de suite ?
Est-ce qu'il faut encore rassurer un peu le consommateur ?
Est-ce qu'il faut venir chercher le consommateur ?
Est-ce qu'il faut venir chercher les développeurs
pour arriver sur une solution grand public et qu'il y ait je dirais une "adoption en masse" ?
C'est une très bonne question
et ça permet de rappeler que c'est une histoire qui est en cours,
qu'on est en train de bâtir ensemble
justement avec les développeurs.
Donc, comme tu l'as très bien mentionné,
il y a déjà des choses qui marchent très très bien.
Il y a déjà des solutions au quotidien et c'est pour ça qu'on continue de vendre
des smartphones aujourd'hui, le week end dernier,
le week-end prochain, pour Noël,
il va se vendre le nova 9,
il va se vendre des produits qui sont disponibles non seulement online,
mais en plus dans les magasins.
Donc, ça veut dire qu’il y a des consommateurs qui viennent les acheter
et ça se passe très bien.
En revanche, c'est vrai que c'est encore à construire.
Ce que je décris, c'est une vision de l'avenir qui va se développer,
se bâtir mois après mois, semaine après semaine et c'est ce qu'on a fait.
Si on prend un peu de recul, il y a deux ans,
il y avait rien dans l’AppGallery qui corresponde aux Français.
Aujourd'hui, on a plus de 1 200 applications françaises qui sont disponibles.
Ça nous a pris un an et demi, presque deux ans.
HarmonyOS, on a commencé il y a quelques mois
en France avec la tablette,
avec une montre : la Watch 3.
Et ça va continuer.
Ça va s'accélérer et en effet 2022 et 2023 vont être des années
très importantes.
On va faire grandir cet écosystème de façon
très concrète, en plus de ce qui existe déjà au quotidien.
Merci beaucoup Stéphane.
Avec plaisir. Merci Aurélien.
Merci à toi, c’était intéressant.
On va continuer à suivre ça dans les temps à venir, bien évidemment.
Je continuerai à tester avec plaisir vos produits.
Puis on va voir l'évolution qui va arriver, comme le tu disais,
entre cette année déjà 2021, 2022,
et puis on regardera ça dans les années à venir.
Quant à vous, je vous remercie d'avoir suivi cette interview.
J'espère que ça vous aura intéressé.
Si vous avez des questions,
des suggestions, des idées, des interrogations,
Vous pouvez tout marquer en bas, en commentaires
et on se retrouve très bientôt.
C’est un format un petit peu à part,
mais c'était très intéressant de faire cette interview avec Stéphane.
Prenez soin de vous. À bientôt.